today on the Matt Walsh show the
canceled culture mob feeds on cowardice
this is what we have to understand the
more that people bow to the mob the more
it will grow in size and strength so
we'll talk about some very recent
examples of egregious cowardice in the
face of the mob and where that all leads
also five headlines including an alleged
rape case at a university that proves
what a sham consent rules are on the
modern college campus and today in our
daily cancellation we're gonna discuss
of course the blatantly racist anti
white comments made by the bigoted Nick
Cannon but he wasn't fired for those
comments he was fired for another reason
we'll talk about all that coming up on
the show today
but first our friends at policy genius
have a message for you you know it's
never a bad idea to save money there's
never a bad time to save money now is
always a good time to start saving money
shopping for life insurance can raise a
lot of questions how much coverage do
you need which insurance company is best
for you how much should it cost and at a
time when it's more important than ever
to have life insurance the pandemic is
making a little more complicated to shop
for it as well
and you got all these questions you
don't know where to turn that's where
policy genius can help I'm telling you
it's a life insurance marketplace backed
by a team of experts policy genius is
keeping track of all the changes in the
market so you don't have to they're
gonna take take all that off your plate
you got enough on your plate already
they're gonna find you the right amount
of cover to the best possible price
without the headache all of your
questions automatically answered policy
genius compares quote from the top life
insurance companies in one place takes
just a few minutes to compare quotes
from the top and shares to find your
best price this doesn't just save a lot
of legwork you could save $1,500 or more
a year as well so you save the lay where
legwork and you save the 1,500 bucks
doesn't get better than that
you need to make sure as well that your
you're just protecting the people who
rely on you it's the right thing to do
it's a smart thing to do and now it's an
easy thing to do too so if you need life
insurance but you're not sure where to
start head to policy genius com policy
genius will help you find the best rates
and handle the process completely
they'll get you and your family
protected and hopefully give you one
less thing to worry about try it today
policy genius comm well the conversation
about can
so culture usually focuses on the mean
bullies in the mob who prowled the Earth
seeking souls to devour and wrong
opinions to punish and they are yes the
primary villains but they aren't the
only ones who keep the canceled culture
mill churning cowards though they are so
often the victims of the cancer culture
also embolden the mob and they
perpetuate the problem
the story of cancel culture is a story
of the gutless legions pouring fuel on
the very fire that consumes them so
cowardice is the real problem I'll give
you a few recent examples probably not
necessary to give examples but I will
anyway because they are instructive last
week a high-ranking executive at Boeing
his name is Neil Golightly which I you
couldn't ask for a more fitting name
than that he he resigned from his
position and issued a groveling apology
after an employee complained about an
article that he had written three
decades ago and in the article he argues
that women should not have a place in
combat roles in the military now in the
editorial which has apparently been
causing this employee untold trauma for
30 years Golightly stated that
introducing women into combat may inter
feel interfere with male quote cohesion
morale efficiency and aggressiveness and
he doubted whether quote women and men
can adapt emotionally to the socially
radical step of fighting side-by-side
now he now calls these comments
offensive and embarrassing and
apologizes for them and is stepping down
in disgrace of course they were not
offensive or wrong he was entirely
correct and I suspect he still knows
that he was correct he's just pretending
otherwise also last week the actress
Halle Berry begged for forgiveness after
it was revealed that she might play a
quote trans man in an upcoming film
following the standard apology script in
these situations Berry said in a
statement as a cisgender woman I now
understand that I should not have
considered this role and that the
transgender community
should undeniably have the opportunity
to tell their own stories I am grateful
for the guidance and critical
conversation of the past few days and
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
but it wasn't a mistake she says she's
gonna learn from her mistake she didn't
make a mistake a transgender man is a
female Halle Berry is a female perfectly
qualified for the role but that
shouldn't even matter because being
qualified for the role of an actor is
just a matter of can you do a good job
pretending to be that thing the whole
job of an actor is to pretend to be
something that you aren't if you're
simply portraying what you already are
it's not acting by definition so the
attacks against her were preposterous on
multiple levels completely wrong but she
caved anyway without even really much
hesitation this week has seen even more
egregious cases listen to these okay you
just you have to listen Gary Garrels a
prominent curator at the San Francisco
Museum of Modern Art probably a guy
being a curator at an Art Museum in San
Francisco I'm assuming a very liberal
guy and probably not someone who ever
thought he'd be the target of the the
liberal mob but he has resigned and
apologized after some staff members
accused him of racism and scientists
started a petition denouncing his quote
toxic white supremacist beliefs now you
hear that you think Wow an art museum
curator in San Francisco was a white
supremacist it's not exactly what you
would expect that's not exactly where
you would expect to find Klan members I
don't know not to be stereotypical but
what specifically were his toxic beliefs
white supremacists toxic beliefs and a
recent staff meeting he said that the
museum would of course trying to be
diverse and everything but they would
still collect some art from white men
and he said he didn't want to commit
reverse discrimination and disqualify
artwork based on the color of an artist
skin that's it that's all he said his
position
that he was taking there was obviously
reasonable and completely right of
course you shouldn't refuse to display
art from someone because they're white
that doesn't make any sense the only
bone that I would pick with his comments
is that discrimination against whites
isn't reverse discrimination
it's just discrimination a racism
against White's the racism of Nick
Cannon for example which we'll talk
about later on in the show
that's not reverse racism that's just
racism reverse discrimination and
reverse racism makes it sound like
discrimination and racism is a white
thing and when someone is racist against
a white person they're reversing they're
taking the sort of giving the white
people a dose of their own medicine by
putting the word reverse in there you're
almost excusing it implicitly so that's
the only bone I would pick but but but
other than that his point was
self-evidently true still he left his
position which he had held for decades
offered a sincere and personal apology
offered this apology to these stupid
disgraceful crybabies on his staff only
he didn't call them stupid disgraceful
crybabies as he should have
instead he validated their lunacy and
their paranoid delusions by acting like
he was somehow in the wrong
and for this contrition and this
accountability Garrels will no doubt be
rewarded with shunning and ostracization
which is exactly what would have
happened if he had just stuck to his
guns and maintained his dignity in the
first place finally another example from
this week this one is the most egregious
of all and will will you got to get a
load of this we'll talk about it in just
one second but first legacy box
you know legacy box was a super simple
mail and service to have all of your
home movies and pictures digitally
preserved on a thumb drive DVD or the
cloud don't let those priceless family
memories disappear because that's what
happens you know if you don't take
action they just they go away you forget
about them they collect dust
you know the and and everything else get
them all in one place easily accessible
if your family members memories are if
your family memories are trapped on old
camcoder tapes or on film reels magnetic
stripes are degrading are not made to
stand the test of time and so there is
some urgency here you know if you if you
think you just leave them in the box and
they'll be fine there forever they won't
be let the science be the solution
disaster happens it's an unfortunate
reality and that's one that we can never
really be prepared for that's the other
problem if you have them stored in a
basement or something I know people
store store that stuff in a basement
flood you know you get some flooding in
the basement destroys everything those
are decades of memories that are out the
window and that's and that's why you
know I use legacy box because I don't
want to leave the stuff somewhere where
I'm gonna forget about it where it's all
disorganized or where you know you get a
eat a little bit of flooding or
something else and it's gonna destroy
all that legacy box is a way for you to
easily affordably digitally preserve
your fat your past and I what I would
emphasize here is how easy it is because
all you're doing is you're taking all
this stuff you're saying it sending it
over to legacy box and they take care of
the rest for you it really is that
simple you've got to give this a try
your family memories are worth it get
started future proofing your memories
today so you can gather the family and
and begin the trip down memory lane go
to legacy box.com slash Walsh to get an
incredible 40 percent off your first
order
buy today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer send in when you're
ready go to legacy box and dot-com slash
Walsh say 40% while supplies last go
there now okay most egregious example
from this week anyway a white business
owner
although the week is yet still young a
white business owner in seattle rachel
marshall published a long apology on
instagram because she wore dreadlocks
marshall it was that's the city she was
wearing dreadlocks apparently i guess
she's had dreadlocks for a long time and
she has decided realized come to the
conclusion been convinced by the
offended masses that this was racist she
said she's gonna get the dreads taken
out as soon as she can she said she's
very
sorry for the harm and pain that her
hairdo caused to black people and she
also promised to hire diversity and
equity representatives to teach her how
to maintain a fair equitable workplace
now she doesn't explain how a hairstyle
could have harmed anyone or caused
anyone pain let alone how it may have
interfered with fairness and equality in
the workplace and she probably doesn't
explain it because it's impossible to
explain because it's nonsense it's also
worth noting here for the record
dreadlocks have been warned by many
cultures for millennia many races
including the white race have a
tradition of wearing dreadlocks going
back thousands of years yes white people
have been wearing dreadlocks for
literally thousands of years in fact
ancient Europeans were among the
earliest to sport dreadlocks and no I
didn't know that off the top of my head
I actually had to look it up this this
is what I've been reduced to because of
all this madness I had to look up the
history of dreadlocks and sure enough
here you go black people did not invent
the style they don't own it even if they
did invent it which again they didn't
they still wouldn't own it because
that's not how style works styles and
fashions change and evolve over time
pulsed cultures are constantly in
exchange with one another importing and
exporting different styles a white
German immigrant invented blue jeans
nobody says that you have to be white or
German to wear blue jeans no one says
that so again the offended mob is
severely wrong on every level and in
every way yet they get what they want
and their wrongness is validated by the
people who should be flipping them the
bird and telling them to piss off many
excuses could be offered of course for
the cowards that I just documented or
they any other you know any of the
countless other cowards who have fallen
to their knees and begged the mobs
forgiveness for saying and doing things
that are unobjectionable by any sane
standard you could say their lives will
be destroyed if they did in they had no
choice they had to comply so on and so
on
that may be true in some cases although
I think that probably the woman with the
dreadlocks wasn't facing any life
destroying consequences and you'd think
that an executive at Boeing would have
the power and resources to stand firm
without falling into bankruptcy and
ruination but we have seen time and time
again that the mob if it wants to will
wreck your life whether you apologize or
not the apology doesn't seem to have any
bearing on the penalty meted out
sometimes often times in fact the the
mob will just move on and find something
else to complain about which is one of
them you know which is one of the main
reasons I've been saying forever you
come up against the outraged mob just
just bide your time
don't apologize just wait for them to
forget about it and move on probably
they will now sometimes they don't and
they're really gonna try to destroy you
but my point is if they do that
it won't matter if you apologize or not
if they really smell blood in the water
and decide that they're gonna they're
gonna just devour you then rather than
taking a couple of nibbles and moving on
then they then they're gonna do it and
there's there's actually nothing you can
say that's gonna stop it so you may as
well maintain your dignity you you may
as well stand stand firm and have some
courage because you literally have
nothing to lose but even if some amount
of financial and professional security
could potentially be maintained by
prostrating oneself and pleading for
absolution
we still must have the courage to defy
the mob and accept the consequences of
that defiance there is always a risk in
being courageous of course that's why we
call it courageous but the risk in
continuing to grovel on command is far
greater the mob only grows in size grows
in power its thirst for vengeance and
domination becomes even more insatiable
over time and justice rationality
liberty and truth recede further into
the background in our culture the only
way to stop this process the only way if
it can be stopped at all at this point
is to stand firm there is no other
solution there is no other way
defy the mob refused to apologize to it
refused to bend to its will or watch as
it takes and destroys everything those
are the only two choices and this is why
when we're blaming people for the
outraged mob the canceled culture mob
one of the groups we must blame are many
of the cowards who have been its victims
so yes there is some victim-blaming
going on here absolutely all right well
let's move on to headlines and I want to
get to the daily cancellation as well
because there's a lot to discuss there
today's five headlines are brought to
you by the Benham brothers learn how to
own a business without it owning you get
a 15% discount on the Benham brothers
new course expert ownership at Benham
brothers dot-com / walsh Benham brothers
dot-com / walsh number one i want to
start with this very instructive case
here this was reported on The Daily
wires as a male student at embry-riddle
Aeronautical University is suing after
the school expelled him for sexual
misconduct even after evidence was
presented that showed he was the victim
the student referred to as John Doe in
court documents says in his lawsuit that
he informed er au that he was too
intoxicated to engage in sexual activity
and witness statements back him up yet
the school relied on antiquated gender
stereotypes about male sexuality to say
hid to say his claim wasn't credible so
that's the that's the introduction to
encase this is here some of the
specifics Jane and John Doe no relation
let's hope girl and guy on this college
campus I suspect that's not the real
names they've been texting for weeks
they meet up at a party I think John is
15 drinks in okay completely hammered
they go back to I think it was his place
and they you know in have they had
sexual relations she initiates sexual
contact with this extremely drunk man
then she spends the night
the next morning she leaves later on she
decides that she was raped even though
she never said during the sexual
activity that she wanted to stop or that
she didn't consent never said that she
was a willing participant the entire
time and again she was the initiator
actually of this sexual activity the
school expels John so now he's suing and
I hope that he bankruptcy school and
takes every dime that it has the
standard of consent on college campuses
is that drunk people cannot consent and
a great many men have been expelled or
worse for having sex with drunk women
now here we have a woman having sex with
a drunk man and witnesses say by the way
that she seemed fine and sober he was
the one that was you know completely
gone so by this standard she is the
rapist she should have been expelled
he's the victim yet he gets the penalty
now in reality of course nobody is the
victim here well he is the victim now
he's a victim in a very serious way
victim of a false rape claim getting
expelled for no reason so he really is a
victim but in terms of the sexual
encounter itself nobody's a victim when
two people get together and willingly
engage in sexual activity with one
another there is no rape that's not rape
if you had one too many drinks or
several too many drinks that doesn't
make it rape either because if it did
then the vast majority of all sexual
contact on college campuses is rape and
often both participants are raping each
other it but the whole notion is just
nonsensical and sick and wrong but again
that's the standard established them's
the rules you know yes we could easily
say that John also was a willing
participant if he never said no he never
tried to leave I by any sane definition
of the term that's certain that's not
right again both if you have to
willing participants in a sexual act
it's not rape a rape by definition is
when one participant is not willing and
is forced to that's that's rape but
that's that's all that's that's normal
sane rational standards that's not the
standard you have on college campuses
and by their standard Jane should be
expelled not John now Eve introducing
rational and sane standards she should
be expelled now at least for making a
false rape claim but even by she should
be expelled two times over actually what
we see at work here is actually as the
article references it's actually kind of
an antiquated chivalrous notion where
the man is more responsible in a sexual
act than the woman is and it's the man's
job to protect the woman from herself
that's the way these issues are handled
on college campuses the man is
responsible for a sexual act that the
woman later regrets even if he was the
drunk one and even if she was the
initiator and even if she was entirely
willfully and did the whole time which
is to say that the woman is what
incompetent helpless not responsible for
her own actions
that's the message being sent here it's
a very paternalistic one might even say
patriarchal message of a woman not being
responsible for her own actions and a
man being penalized for not protecting
her from her own self feminists should
be up in arms about this but of course
they're not number two here's the
headline from pink News UK's biggest
cervical cancer charity shuts down
disgustingly transphobic lie that only
females get cervical cancer yes their
their transphobic lie but by the way in
case you didn't know dear dear audience
only a female has a cervix so yes only
females can get cervical cancer
typically the way this works and I'm not
a doctor I admit but my understanding
anyway
is that you can only get cancer of a
body part
that you you know actually have so
that's one of the reasons why funnily
enough I've never suffered a damage to
my wing or a ruptured gill plate you
know because I don't have those things
I've also never had canine distemper or
feline leukemia it's pretty amazing the
other day I went to the doctor for a
physical and he came back and told me
that thank God my elephant tusks are not
infected and I was pretty relieved by
that many explained that's the reason
they're not affected is because actually
I don't have any so that that that was
pretty great but remember this is the
pro science side okay the side that
holds the most anti science position the
modern world has ever seen war this is
worse even than flat earther ism a lot
of times we criticize anti science or
pseudoscience positions by saying this
is like saying the earth is flat this is
worse than saying the earth is flat this
is actually a lot worse but this is the
pro science side remember that it's
important prosigns number three I never
thought I'd actually say this but Terry
Crews for president I actually think the
president from idiocracy should be the
real president
ironically Cruz of course has been in
the news recently pushing back against
the false narratives from BLM which here
is an example of courage in the face of
the cancel mob okay this is a man for a
man in his position a black man to take
that stance publicly okay that takes
guts especially as a guy who you know he
makes his living doing things on
mainstream media he's like the host of
America's Got Talent or he was anyway
we'll see how that goes
he works for mainstream media companies
they aren't gonna like what he's saying
he is probably gonna suffer financially
for this but he sticks to it anyway and
that and that's exactly what needs to
happen that takes courage you deserves a
lot of credit for that here's the latest
from him he says I said a tweet from him
where he says defund pornhub and then
tags fight the new drug so he's going
after pornhub now now you know me he won
my vote right there
I just hands-down that's my vote but I
but this is what I really love about it
he goes from publicly defending one of
the most unpopular opinions you can
possibly take these days goes from that
to taking taking an even more unpopular
position so he's saying to the cancel
mob oh you didn't like what I said over
that well get a look get a load of this
over here you're really you're really
not gonna like this it's almost like
he's doing it on purpose as a middle
finger to the outraged mob and I love
that because that's exactly what we need
to do president Terry Crews let's make
it happen number four a little bit of
good news to come out of this pandemic
no fans are gonna be allowed at Eagles
or Phillies home games apparently that's
the latest news out of that now I'm not
in favor of the lock downs and I really
don't see why we have to keep fans out
of the stadiums why can't you fill them
to 30% or 40% capacity or whatever it is
but I am in favor of banning all Philly
sports fans from all venues and all
places everywhere permanently that I can
endorse you know for public health and
all of that
number five world of beer in Hartford
Connecticut has pulled pulled from its
collection in an expensive bottle of
beer because customers were complaining
about it the beer was made apparently to
raise awareness and fight racism it's an
anti racism beer and it was served to a
black customer who recently who I
suppose was meant to be impressed and
appreciate the anti racism mists of the
beer but something was lost in
translation because well here's here's
here's the beer take a look at that's
what the beer so the beer looks like
right there it's a it's a beer dressed
up in Klan robes that's what they do now
in fairness it does say yellow the name
of the beer is yellow bellied which is
an insult so I guess you could say
they're calling the Klan yellow bellies
now it's an insult nobody is used since
1875 but still yet it you know somehow
shockingly that
didn't exactly resonate and this brings
to mind an old adage which you know is
go go won't go broke or maybe it's get
woke go broke or go won't get broke
anyway woke and broke is the idea they
tried to be woke but they accidentally
ended up promoting the Klan which it's
it can happen to anyone
that's it happens but that's why it's
better to just make your beer as just
make your beer a beer beer should just
be beer don't worry about making your
beer socially conscious in fact
personally I prefer for my beer to be
totally unconscious having a conscious
beer freaks me out so that's the way I
would handle that where you get to our
daily cancellation all of this stuff
with Nick Cannon in just a second but
you know in midst of all this news we
just talked about everything that's
going on Ben Shapiro has a new book
called how to destroy America in 3 easy
steps you must have seen in the future
when he's writing this thing because
this everything that's in the book has
come to life all around us unfortunately
the book goes on sale Tuesday July 21st
at 6 p.m. Eastern 3 p.m. Pacific Ben
will be doing a virtual live signing
event on the day of the release with
your purchase of a signed book you can
write in a question which may be read
and answered as he signs all the books
now you can pre-order your signed copy
go there now daily wire.com slash Ben
how to destroy America in 3 easy steps
details how this alternate world view
you know is is is gaining so much
traction in America and also destroying
our country all around us as we watch so
you got to read this book very pertinent
very current and relevant again that's
daily wire.com slash Ben to order your
signed copy and join Ben's live signing
on Tuesday July 21st ok today for our
daily cancellation we're gonna be
canceling Viacom for firing Nick Cannon
after he made racist anti white comments
I'm canceling Viacom for canceling to
Cannon but we're not canceling them for
firing him we're cancelling them because
they didn't fire him forth for the anti
white comments so let's go back and and
and go over this again a clip from Nick
Cannon's podcast went viral yesterday
and in the clip he's
babbling incoherently so it's kind of
hard to understand what he's trying to
say but he does make his feelings about
white people loud and clear when we talk
about the power of Mellon 80 people when
we talk about who we really are as gods
and right and and that our melanin is so
power and it connects us in a way that
the reason why they fear black the
reason why they fear is because they the
lack that they have of it so then when
you see what's you know dr. Francis II
wasn't talked about is that fear in that
that they genetically shishun see we'd
have a person that has has the lack of
pigment the lack of melon right that
they know that they will be annihilated
so therefore however they got the power
they they have the lack of compassion
that melanin comes with compassion
melanin comes with sold and we know we
call it soul weed so brothers and
sisters
that's the melanin that connect all the
people that don't have it have are are
lit and I'm gonna say this carefully are
a little less and and in where the term
actually comes from because I'm bringing
it all the way back around okay to
Minister Farrakhan to where they may not
have the compassion or the the when they
were sent to the mountains of Caucasus
when they when they didn't have the
power of the Sun that was that the Sun
then started to deteriorate so then
they're acting out of fear they're
acting out of low self-esteem
they're acting out of a deficiency so
therefore the only way that they can act
is evil the only way they can they have
to rob steal rape kill and finally
slightly more in order to survive
exactly so then these people who didn't
have but we had and when I say we I
speak of Mellon ated people right they
had to be savages they had to be
barbaric they had because they're in
these Nordic mountains they're in these
rough torrential environments so me
they're acting as animals right so
they're the ones that are actually
closer to animals they're the ones that
are actually the truth savages okay so
to review white people are a little less
evil savages barbaric closer to animals
plus we don't have souls compassion or
self-esteem and we rob kill and rape
he he he put all that into into you know
two minutes you have to sift through a
lot of incomprehensible nonsense to get
to it but that's that's what he was
trying to say he does also appear to
think that melanin in the skin is like
some kind of magical elixir some sort of
supernatural formula that imbues soul
and compassion and other things into
people he sees melanin like it's almost
like he sees it as what's the thing from
Star Wars
the thing that Jedi have that makes them
that gives them super powers my tall or
mitochondria what I know it's not that
whatever it is melanin is like that what
the Jedi have and of course that's all
pseudo scientific inanity it doesn't
make any sense at all but the real issue
here is the stuff you said about white
people and the fact that he thinks that
were evil soulless savages that that I
think is the headline it is actually
helpful though I have to say I'm
actually grateful to the bigoted Nick
Cannon for saying this because the term
racism is thrown around so much that you
you forget what it means it's you can
easily forget what racism means because
we're calling everything racism these
days and you know even even someone's
hairstyle or an art art curator
collecting our art from white white
artists yeah we're calling that racist
so after a while maybe you forget it the
the term loses its meaning and then you
see this and you realize oh okay that's
what racism is that right there
racism is a guide to grading an entire
race of people and outright saying they
are less than him and savage and evil
that is racism and that is literally
supremacism that is black supremacism
that we're seeing there too at
e-textbook racism
maybe not modern textbook racism because
they're changing the definition but any
a real textbook racism right there any
white person who said that goes without
saying yes if you can even imagine
a a white person of any prominence
whatsoever saying anything like that
about black people or any other race
they would be fired shunned canceled
destroyed in a heartbeat without
hesitation without question and not one
person anywhere would defend them nor
should they nor would I you see
objecting the cancel culture doesn't
mean that we have to take the position
that nobody should ever suffer any
consequences for anything they do or say
that would be silly of course that's
that's that's not what we mean when we
talk about cancel calls or at least it's
not what I mean
cancel culture is about shutting down
intelligent debate punishing people for
doing and saying things that are not
actually objectionable and oftentimes
correct and cancel culture is all is is
also disproportionate so it could be
that that someone says or does something
that is objectionable but the response
is totally out of proportion so for
example some kids playing around with
dough at Jimmy John's become national
pariahs that is a consequence that is
way out of proportion to the crime these
are not public figures these are just
some kids being stupid yeah they're
gonna lose their job at Jimmy John's but
to have their face plastered all over
the place to be to be denounced in
mainstream publications across the the
country and the globe way out of
proportion
that's cancel culture cancel culture
also goes digging for offenses okay the
cancel culture mob is looking to be
offended they're looking for things
finding things people said and did long
ago to destroy them a you know article
someone wrote 33 years ago about women
in combat which also wasn't even
objectionable it was completely correct
but that's how cut cancel culture babes
in this case it's completely different
we have a prominent person saying
something publicly saying it now not
saying it thirty years ago and what
they're saying is wrong and extreme
objectionable and actually racist by any
sane definition of the term so this is
not yes he should be fired for that
absolutely and again if it was a white
person nobody would be saying that they
should who was a white celebrity works
for a major media company and they went
out and said about another race that
they're savage is an evil and less than
him nobody would be saying don't fire
him of course they're gonna fire him for
that well what else is a company gonna
do is a state know the company's not
gonna stand by they shouldn't have to
stand by you for that you're the one who
decided to come out and say that and now
you know you need to accept the
consequences it's not the company's job
to you know take the slings and arrows
for you being a revolting stupid insane
bigot but and so he is fired right but
the problem is that he wasn't fired for
that here's the statement from Viacom
Viacom CBS denounces bigotry of any kind
and we categorically denounce all forms
of anti-semitism we have spoken with
Nick Cannon about an episode of his
podcast cannons class on YouTube which
promoted hateful speech and spread
anti-semitic conspiracy theories while
we support ongoing education in dialog
in the fight against bigotry we are
deeply troubled that Nick has failed to
acknowledge or apologize for
perpetuating anti-semitism and we are
terminating our relationship with him
okay wait a second anti-semitic what
wasn't anti-semitic it was it was just
it was anti white in general is bigoted
against all white people wasn't focus
exclusively on Jewish people what are
they talking about well it turns out
that Nick Cannon went on a bit of a
bigotry spree during that episode and
also at one point said that quote
Semitic people are black people and
quote you can't be anti-semitic when we
are the Semitic people when we are the
same people they want to be that's our
birthright and he also said that black
people are the true Hebrews that's what
they fired him for even though that that
what I just well you just heard there is
while nonsensical and weird and
incorrect and objectionable it is wait a
mur then what he said about white people
in general I mean
remember he called white people evil
savages for God's sake it literally does
not get more racist than that that is
the height of racist language you you
couldn't you couldn't possibly be more
racist that's as racist as it gets but
and this is why Viacom is cancelled they
couldn't bring themselves to fire Nick
Cannon for anti-white racism or even
even to denounce it to acknowledge it
it's smacking them anti-white racism
smacking them in the face with a
sledgehammer which these days often it
does in a literal sense as well but they
couldn't do it he's out here calling
white people soulless barbarians and
they don't fire him for it
they don't even specifically mention it
in their in their announcement of his
termination instead they use the the
Semitic comments as a excuse to dump him
this is how trendy and acceptable
anti-white racism is you can denounce
white people as subhuman monsters and
you won't lose your job for it you may
lose your job for something else your
company may find some other reason to
dump you because they're afraid of what
you might say next but that's not gonna
be the reason they state they're gonna
find something else and they certainly
won't come out and say anti-white racism
is bad and we reject it think about how
crazy that actually is it is now edgy it
is controversial it is provocative it is
offensive to simply say that it's bad to
hate all white people that statement now
is is is like you know people don't want
to say that it's actually racist to say
that I've been told this directly that
to speak out against anti-white racism
is itself racist it is racist to be
opposed to anti-white racism that's
where we are and we should also mention
that if you go on on Twitter or social
media you're gonna find that there is a
lot of support for what Nick Cannon said
not just for him not just people saying
oh you let him have a second chance or
whatever people supporting what he
actually said look yes I agree with it
white people are soulless barbarians who
are
human and lack compassion there's a lot
of that anti-white racism is the only
mainstream form of racism I didn't say
it's the only form of racism exist in
the world it's the only kind that is
acceptable in the mainstream not just
acceptable not just tolerated but
oftentimes celebrated and so if you
pretend to be against racism and
fighting racism but you're not
acknowledging this kind of racism then
you're just a cowardly hypocritical
fraud and there are a lot of those to go
around these days and we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 a major liberal writer
resigns and discussed from the New York
Times a black celebrity calls white
people animals and the federal
government starts killing criminals
again check it out on the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]